muy Bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
la entrevista de France 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña Alexandra
Fernández ella es activista por los
derechos de los animales junto a ella
Vamos a hablar sobre especismo y
derechos animales Alessandra Fernández
Muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de Fran 24
Gracias Santiago
gracias a vos una vez más bueno en
primer lugar preguntarte por supuesto
que es el especismo para contárselo a
nuestra audiencia
bien bueno podríamos decir que el
especismo es una discriminación que se
da En aquellos sujetos que no pertenecen
a una determinada especie lo más común
de ver es el antropocentrismo el
especismo antropocéntrico digo que es el
que se da cuando los seres humanos
pensamos que somos sujetos de mayor
consideración moral que que individuos
de otras especies pero también somos
capaces de arbitrariamente decidir que
algunas especies tienen según la cultura
en la que estemos mayor consideración
moral que otras como bueno en nuestro
caso es bastante común ver perros y
gatos que nosotros por cuestiones quizás
de afinidad o los lazos que
culturalmente hemos construido con ellos
somos capaces de poder empatizar y de
entender sus sus intereses y incluso
Hemos llegado a luchar por leyes que
protegen sus derechos en muchas ciudades
y países del mundo no Y esto no pasa con
con otras es como cerdos pollos vacas
etcétera de animales que son usados para
nuestro propio beneficio una imagen
clave en este sentido Alessandra por
ejemplo
esos camiones repletos de vacas o de
gallinas por ejemplo que quizás no
suelen causar o en gran parte de la
población mayores impresiones no hay una
suerte de naturalización de esas
imágenes Pero quizás sí se ve esa misma
imagen como vos decías no con perros o
con gatos causaría otro impacto no
Entonces te quiero preguntar qué hay
detrás de este especismo que imaginarios
qué educación recibida está allí no en
el germen de este especismo
sí Bueno es muy común esto esto que
decir de hecho un ejemplo es Es que
nosotros en nuestros países en
Latinoamérica normalmente criticamos y
vemos con muy malos ojos lo que sucede
en China como el consumo de perros y
gatos que hay ciertas provincias en ese
país en el que eso es naturalizado pero
no nos detenemos a pensar que nosotros
hacemos Exactamente lo mismo con otras
especies animales no Y esto viene de una
educación que es claramente especista
diseñada por un sistema en el que estos
animales son son los que están más
alejados digamos de todo poder de
derecho de que sean sus intereses
considerados y y nos los venden desde
que somos muy chiquititos No yo por
ejemplo hasta mi adolescencia fue que yo
pude darme cuenta de que esto pasaba y
dejé de comer carne Aproximadamente a
los 16 años cuando pude empezar a tener
un cierto raciocinio y a poder tomar en
cuenta
tenemos las cosas que creía que podía yo
argumentar en contra no pero cuando
somos chiquitos vemos cómo nos enseñan
que que por ejemplo las vacas dan leche
cuando eso es mentira las vacas dan
leche Sí pero porque cualquier mamífero
da leche cuando está embarazada no
entonces esa leche lo que nosotros los
humanos hacemos Es explotarla para que
ellas den mucha más leche de la que
deberían poder dar naturalmente y una
leche que que debería ser para su
ternero es es vendida para los seres
humanos que somos los únicos que
consumimos leche después de nuestra
etapa de bebés no entonces
son ese tipo de cosas como Este ejemplo
que doy de las vacas que claramente
hacen que tengamos una disonancia
cognitiva en nuestra adultes y que
veamos todos estos problemas con los
ojos cerrados no y que realmente en la
sociedad hay muchos problemas y cuando
no podemos ver esos problemas no podemos
definirlos entonces para nosotros no hay
un problema para poder resolver un
problema primero hay que poder verlo y
cuando nos hacen esta disonancia Nada es
imposible poder ver ese problema no
hablabas del consumo de carne no de esta
idea naturalizada no de que las vacas
dan leche no como si fuera prácticamente
una función no es natural que tienen Y
entonces ingresamos en lo que es la
industria alimentaria No la que más
víctimas animales no humanos genera
manejas unas cifras Alessandra que son
escalofriantes podrías contarnos las
si estas estas cifras probablemente a
día de hoy sean mayores Lamentablemente
porque el consumo de animales Así como
si bien cada vez hay más personas que
eligen no no alimentarse de animales no
humanos También tenemos una población
que sigue creciendo no Entonces eso
obviamente conlleva que cada vez se
consuma más animales pero las últimas
cifras dadas por organizaciones
comonds que es una organización de de
Inglaterra si no me equivoco
dan que aproximadamente se matan más de
4.600 millones de animales por día lo
que da una cifra de un billón 684 mil
millones de animales asesinados por año
es una cifra que que ni siquiera Ya
acaba en nuestra cabeza de poder
dimensionar pero un ejemplo como para
que la gente pueda llegar a entenderlo
quizás más
es que en menos de un mes se matan a más
animales que todas las personas que han
vivido en 200.000 años de historia de la
humanidad y esto no lo digo yo esto
estaba estadísticamente comprobado que
imagen impactante Alexandra haremos
ahora de la raíz de esta discriminación
no de la que estamos hablando que no es
diferente no a la que sufren ciertos
individuos Como por ejemplo que sufren
el racismo o el sexismo entonces la
lucha por los derechos de los animales
está ligada no a otras Como por ejemplo
el anticlasista la anti racista estamos
hablando En definitiva De todas formas
de pensamiento jerárquico no y de
ciertas opresiones
sí acá Santiago Está bueno traer un
término que que se ha estado haciendo un
poco Popular en los últimos años gracias
a un artista afroamericana en Estados
Unidos que es el término de la
interseccionalidad Y es que muchos
problemas de Justicia social no como lo
es el especismo
y bueno también el racismo el sexismo y
otros que que vos nombraste bastante
bien a menudo se superponen creando
múltiples niveles de injusticia social
por ejemplo una mujer
afrodescendiente va a tener
probablemente vivencias
distintas a un hombre afrodescendiente
Porque a ella la intersectan estos ejes
de lo que es la discriminación por ser
mujeres y por su raza no
en el caso de los animales es bastante
difícil poder ver eso porque son como yo
decía antes sujetos que entra de lo que
ella escala de
privilegios o de derechos Si se quiere
son los que están más alejados de ellos
de hecho como yo decía solamente Algunos
perros gatos y quizás a nivel muy
aislado en el mundo algunas otras
especies se les ha dado derechos pero a
nivel legal estos animales no tienen
ningún derecho son propiedades de los
humanos Entonces no somos siquiera
capaces de poder dimensionar esa
realidad no pero son los sujetos que
están más alejados de ese centro de
consideración moral entonces a mi modo
de verlo creo que cualquier sistema o
cualquier lucha social que queramos
hacer sea como el feminismo que es una
lucha muy loable o la lucha contra el
racismo tiene que abrazar y tiene que
abanderar también a otras luchas
sociales porque no se puede luchar
contra algo y al mismo tiempo oprimir a
otros sujetos entonces
creo que la forma más coherente de poder
ver la libertad individual de las
personas es incluyendo también a los
animales no humanos y Por ende abrazar
de la lucha contra el Espejismo entonces
creo que todo movimiento social debe ser
interseccional y antiespecista es clave
Alessandra Entonces en este sentido
considerar a los animales como sujetos
plenos de derecho verdad
Y sintientes perdona además Sí
perdón me repetís lo último y sintientes
además
claro Sí es que justamente Ahí viene la
la cuestión que que nosotros desde el
movimiento antiespecista
defendemos no a una breve definición
para que la gente Quizás lo entienda
porque por ahí digo antes especímenes
como Qué es eso y es una postura que
defiende justamente que los animales de
otras especies a la humana son
moralmente relevantes por sí mismos por
su capacidad de sentir y de tener una
vida experiencial y no en función de su
valor instrumental
por tanto no hay razones justificadas
para considerar que que los intereses de
estos animales son menos valiosos que
los intereses humanos y por tanto estos
filosóficamente rechaza la idea de que
los intereses humanos deben ser
priorizados sobre los de los de las
demás especies
muchas veces cuando una dice que que
quiere derechos para los para estos
animales la gente por ahí te argumento
de que no Bueno pero ellos Qué derechos
van a tener no van a votar y esto
incluso es como bastante interesante
porque lo mismo se decía con las mujeres
cuando no podían votar No pero en este
caso nosotros estamos pidiendo que los
animales voten estamos pidiendo que se
respeten sus intereses básicos que son
el derecho a la vida el derecho a
respetar esos intereses básicos que
cualquier individuo sintiente tiene como
evitar el dolor Buscar el placer
etcétera eso lo podemos ver en cualquier
individuo sintiendo Ahora hay algo muy
interesante Alessandra que has plantado
en alguna oportunidad Y es que existe
una resistencia animal verdad acaso que
lo demuestran
hay animales y esto se ha documentados
se puede ver en internet hay animales
que Que obviamente intentan defenderse
del no de de la opresión así como
cualquier persona digamos la cual se le
está
digamos haciendo algún mal en el que
estás sintiendo ese dolor y tratadas
como quizás más por instinto No lo sé
pero intentas rechazar No ese dolor
porque justamente no hay de tu interés
estar en una situación de de sentir
dolor Entonces esto se ha visto en
numerosas veces en animales podemos
comprar nosotros mismos no ningún animal
le va a gustar que que le hagas daño se
va a tratar de defender lo que pasa es
que en estos sistemas creados de formas
tales que que ellos no puedan defenderse
no no no no no lo podemos llegar a ver
pero sí hemos visto incluso animales que
se han escapado de camiones de mataderos
etcétera tratando de esca la realidad
que que algunos llegan a ver porque ven
como a sus compañeros
lo llevan o le generan cierto maltrato y
y hay animales que son capaces de poder
darse cuenta de estas cosas no
como también lo hacemos nosotros Claro
Alexandra Fernández bueno Se nos acabó
el tiempo Lamentablemente se pasó
rapidísimo Muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de Franz 24
en español ha sido un placer dialogar
contigo
una vez más a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto
entradas 24.com 100 junto a nosotros
[Música]